in 2020 while we were all fighting
against the covet-19 pandemic
many of us were fighting a silent battle
a battle against cancer we lost
more than one million europeans to this
disease
parents friends loved ones
and sadly the number of cases is on the
rise
and this is why we present europe's
beating cancer plan today
we have set ourselves ambitious goals
we want to save lives through prevention
we want to detect cancer as early as
possible
we want to ensure access to the highest
standards of diagnosis and treatment
and we want to improve the quality of
life
of cancer patients and survivors
on our way towards reaching those goals
we define
clear targets and significant funding in
particular through our research program
horizon europe
our overarching matter of concern
is to provide to citizens equal access
across the european union
to modern technologies of detection and
treatment
to the same high standards of care
and to comprehensive support to patients
and their families the fight of those
battling cancer
is our fight as well in europe